today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
all right let's begin with last night's
vice presidential debate
between vice president mike pence and
joe biden's running mate kamala harris
senator from california
expectations were very high for kamala
harris her experience as a prosecutor
and certainly her performances
during testimony in the senate have been
parts of have been elements of why
expectations were very
high for how she would do and she did
well and i believe that she
won the debate to the extent that there
was a winner but i do think that she was
not nearly as tough on mike pence as she
was on joe biden
during democratic primary debates i
think there were missed opportunities
but i'm going to say more about that
in a little bit but the big picture here
if we want to
we don't want to miss the forest for the
trees and the big picture is that kamala
harris
did well on everything coronavirus
related
she did okay on economic issues and she
was sort of
so so on some other topics which we will
discuss
but if you ask me what will the impact
of this debate
be on the election i believe that it is
almost zero
it's it's not zero but it's very very
close to zero
because with everything going on with
donald trump behind in the polls donald
trump
releasing videos from the white house in
which he really doesn't look good which
we will talk about
nothing happened in this debate that
will
change the polling very much and that's
not good for donald trump and mike pence
because
if you believe the polling is even
roughly accurate they need something to
put them back in the lead
and the most likely scenario is that in
the next 72 48
24 in the next five minutes some new
scandal will
will pop up and the vice presidential
debate will be all but forgotten but
let's look at a few
moments from it first of all the fact
that there even was plexiglas
installed at the last minute between the
candidates that's not good for mike
pence the the plexiglas
being needed is a topic
that in and of itself is an indictment
of the trump pence handling of
coronavirus and
indeed they went right into coronavirus
it was the first question
i actually think this was kamala
harris's best moment
of the entire debate coming right at the
beginning well
the american people have witnessed what
is
the greatest failure of any presidential
administration in the history of our
country
and here are the facts 210 000
dead people in our country in just the
last several months
over seven million people who have
contracted this disease
one in five businesses closed
we're looking at frontline workers who
have been treated
like sacrificial workers we are looking
at
over 30 million people
who in the last several months had to
file for unemployment
and here's the thing on january 28th
the vice president and the president
were informed
about the nature of this pandemic they
were informed that it's lethal
in consequence that it is airborne that
it will affect
young people and that it would
be contracted because it is airborne
and they knew what was happening and
they didn't tell
you can you imagine so this was kamala's
best moment if you watched
only the first question or only the
first 10-minute segment which was on
coronavirus and then you bailed on the
debate
you would come away with the best
possible impression of how it went for
kamala harris
the rest of the debate was more mixed
because mike pence kept
going over his time sometimes by as much
as a minute the moderator was unable to
get him under control
mike pence would continually avoid
answering the actual question being
discussed by going back and answering
the previous question
or going two questions back at one point
it got so bad i wondered if pence was
going to ask
to spend some time on questions from his
2016 debate with tim kaine he just
wanted to set the agenda himself
and combining that with the kind of calm
arrogant delivery that pence is known
for
i think certainly he came up uh
looking good enough that his base
is not going to say i can no longer
support trump pence because of pence
whether any undecideds were convinced to
the extent that they still remain
much less clear here's an example of
pence doing this pence asked why does
the u.s have a much higher death rate
than just about every other country
mike pence just talks about something
else higher
than that of almost every other wealthy
country and you have two minutes to
respond without interruption
susan thank you and i want to thank the
commission and the university of utah
for
hosting this event and uh senator harris
it's privileged to be on the stage with
you
and our nation has gone through a very
challenging time this year
but i want the american people to know
that from the very
first day president donald trump has put
the health of america first
before there were more than five cases
in the united states
all people who had returned from china
so i'll spare you the torture but he did
about two minutes of that without
actually answering
why does the united states have one of
the highest death
rates per capita in the world from
coronavirus
in another moment mike pence was asked
about that super spreader event that
they held at the white house not this
past saturday but the previous one
the nomination party for amy coney
barrett
and uh of course we know that that event
was at least partially responsible for
multiple
instances multiple cases of coronavirus
related to the white house watch pence
just bail out
to speak up on behalf of what the
american people have done vice president
pence you were in the front row
in a rose garden event 11 days ago what
seems to have been a super spreader
event for senior administration and
congressional officials
no social distancing few masks and now
a cluster of coronavirus cases among
those who were there
how can you expect americans to follow
the administration's safety guidelines
to protect themselves from covet
when you at the white house have not
been doing so
well the american people have
demonstrated
over the last eight months that when
given the facts they're willing to put
the health of their families and their
neighbors and people they don't even
know
first president trump and i have great
confidence in
in the american people and and their
ability
to take that information and put it into
practice
in the height of the epidemic so that is
not
pence building to some kind of clear
answer about the super spreader event at
the white house
that's pence ranting and raving about
other things and that was the entire
debate
here's an example of mike pence
apparently realizing that the
coronavirus portion of the debate at the
beginning did not go well for him
here is pence asked about presidential
health and age and disability
and mike pence just says well i'm going
to keep talking about coronavirus
had a conversation or reached an
agreement
with president trump about safeguards or
procedures when it comes to the issue
of presidential disability and if not
do you think you should you have two
minutes without interruption
well susan uh thank you although i would
like to go back
i think we need to move on well thank
you but i would like to go back
because the reality is that we're going
to have a vaccine
senator in record time that was the
whole debate i won't give you more
examples of that
mike pence also did some of his normal
theatrics which include
refusing to accept the science on
climate change
repeating donald trump's talking point
about how
forest fires could be solved by forest
management
which they claim democrats are either
against or aren't doing
and then maybe the most bizarre moment
of the debate was when
a fly landed on mike pence's head and
stayed there for minutes and
the the fly landing on mike pence's head
was funny to start with but the fact
that it seemed to be stuck in mike
pence's hair gel
was even funnier and uh that instantly
became a viral moment
the joe biden campaign immediately
starting to sell fly swatters
and you know many many uh allegories
made
to the biblical meaning of when a fly
lands
lands on you for those more religious
folks in the audience it's it's ominous
it's not good
uh but the moment that many say was
kamala harris's
worst of the debate was when the topic
of packing the courts came up
now the question came up during the
biden trump debate last week and the
question
is if joe biden is elected
and republicans confirm amy coney
barrett to the supreme court will joe
biden pack the supreme court
meaning add seats to the supreme court
and
kamala harris much like joe biden did
not give a yes or no answer
and there's a lot of people who are
saying it looks really bad for kamala
not to answer the question i'm not so
sure
let me explain there clearly has been a
strategic decision made
by the biden campaign not to answer yes
or no about whether joe biden would pack
the court
uh i don't think court packing is a
voting
issue for many people so really there's
a lot of potential downside to giving a
straight answer and i'll explain what i
mean if they say yes or no
they number one make the answer the
focus
rather than the threat of using this in
the future
and if you answer yes or no the unknown
threat of maybe biden will pack the
court
goes away and so i understand the risk
when you decide you're not going to
answer a question there's a risk that
you're going to appear evasive
but i understand the strategy because i
don't think there's much to gain
by saying definitively yes or no if
biden and harris say
yes if amy coney barrett gets confirmed
we will pack the court
the right and those on the left who
don't want the court pact
will go crazy and that becomes the focus
rather than republican hypocrisy
about confirming amy coney barrett with
just days left before an election
if biden harris say we won't pack the
court
they bail out the gop and they're
basically saying
even if you confirm amy coney barrett
don't worry we're not going to pack the
court so while i accept that harris
didn't answer
i actually understand why and it will be
a question as to whether it works or
doesn't work
but that but i i get the strategy mike
pence also during the debate seemed to
have a fat lip
and his left eye was either bloody with
a burst blood vessel
or with pink eye which can sometimes
happen with coronavirus
so it was impossible not to notice his
physical appearance during the debate
it was bizarre but big picture the
debate
was not a nothing burger i think that
you saw
how you know when kamala harris went
after joe biden in the primary
you imagined there would be more
ferocity and energy from her against
mike pence
and i took live calls last night after
the debate and a bunch of my callers
said you know sometimes
when women are assertive or aggressive
in popular culture
it counts against them the martha
stewart effect as it's sometimes been
described
and i think that that is absolutely true
to a degree
i still would have liked to see a
balanced approach that had kamala harris
more on the offensive which we know she
can do we've seen her do it in the
senate
we've seen her do it in other contexts
but the big picture is i don't think the
debate is going to change a thing and
when the polling is looking so bad
for trump and pence with now only 25
days left until this election
they need something to turn it around
and this debate is not going to be the
thing that doesn't
we let's talk about the polling we all
must be cautious careful and diligent in
our participation in this election we
all must vote we almost
get people to vote but as a brief
interlude to our discussion of the last
24 hours
polling has completely imploded this
week for donald trump
i'm going to go through with you all of
the new polling
now that we are just 25 26 days from the
election
and it is a very veritable disaster for
donald trump if these numbers are even
remotely accurate and if voter
suppression and dirty tricks
don't end up being how trump claws his
way back up
this could be really bad for trump if if
if
if we vote and remember this polling is
all
post-first debate and it is post-trump
getting coronavirus
and pulling his covita stunt on the
white house portico
so first nationally joe biden is plus
nine
in a new poll plus ten in a new poll
and shockingly plus 12 in a new
rasmussen poll typically one of the most
right-wing polls that we have
if you look overall at recent national
polls this now pushes joe biden's
advantage to an
average of 9.4 points over donald trump
as you can see in the trend lines it is
not going in the right direction for
trump the recent reversal
with a trump decline and biden ascension
started on september 29th that's where
we've seen this drop for trump start
september 29th now
let's not go crazy we still have almost
four weeks to go
if we look at trump versus hillary 26
days out
from the election back in 2016 remember
in 2016 the election was on november 8
so if we go back 26 days from the 2016
election
hillary's lead was 6.7 so yes
joe biden's lead today is bigger than
hillary's four years ago
but hillary was also climbing at this
point in 2016
and biden's lead now is only 40
bigger than hillary's was you might
remember i told you a few days ago
biden's lead today is a hundred and
forty percent bigger than hillary's was
at this point four years ago biden's
lead is growing but hillary's was
growing even more quickly at this point
in time so let's just
understand that not become complacent
now let's look at some state polls
remember we have an electoral college
system in this country
where each state is worth a certain
number of electoral votes 270 being the
total you need
to clinch the presidency the latest
state polls
are very bad for trump yesterday we had
a new marquette poll
for wisconsin and biden is plus five
that's good for biden
ohio according to new york times sienna
biden is
plus one if biden wins ohio you can
essentially
say goodbye to donald trump in
pennsylvania from emerson biden is plus
five
but then we have a quinnipiac poll which
has biden
up 13 in pennsylvania 11
in florida which is just incredible and
five
in iowa and then also notable yesterday
uh new york times sienna poll says biden
is up six
in nevada and even the poll out of west
virginia that says trump is up
18. remember that in 1919
in 2016 a trump won west virginia by 42.
if indeed trump wins west virginia by
only 18
that would be a very small margin of
victory in one of the reddest
states in the country so the debate
clearly did not work well for donald
trump having coronavirus pulling his
corona ride and covida stunts
have not helped him and now we will wait
and see
what the impact of the vice presidential
debate is
if any let me know what you think it
will be
i'm on twitter at d pacman the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember to grab a membership at
joinpacman.com
and support the david pakman show we
have a great place
uh on the internet for you to engage
with our other viewers and listeners
it's the david pakman show
subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
reddit a few interesting posts uh from
this morning
if trump loses the election fair and
square what do you think he'll do as
president during
during the interregnum period also known
as lame duck
i think this is um a user on our
subreddit i think he'll probably pull a
matt bevin and pardon a bunch of heinous
criminals murders rapists etc
that's his way of lashing out against
the public who he
will feel betrayed him uh i also think
he'll probably try to start a war or
something before he leaves office so he
can hand the conflict over to biden i
don't know about starting a war i do
think that if trump loses
and it is clear that he lost and trump
has no way to argue he didn't lose
i do think that there is a real risk of
complete and total insanity during that
lame duck period now
hopefully by that point the world will
be so desperate for
normal uh people in the white house that
joe biden will essentially become
the president in waiting he will be
running a parallel presidency directly
interacting with world leaders
and donald trump will immediately be
pushed to the margins but let's not put
the cart before the horse and remember
my other concern is physical violence
physical violence from trump supporters
during that lame duck period
if they believe donald trump had it
stolen from him so
let's take it a day at a time let's
first remove trump
then we'll figure out how to handle the
lame duck period another post from the
subreddit
says joe biden should not attend the
debate next week
i knew someone who experienced covid
symptoms for five weeks
and was probably still infectious during
that time we have no idea what trump is
truly experiencing right now he'll still
likely be contagious next thursday biden
should not participate well
joe biden may have been bailed out
because donald trump now says
he will not participate because the
commission on presidential debates
has decided as of this second it already
may have changed by the time we get
today's show out as of this second
the cpd says next week's debate will be
remote
because of the situation as we know it
uh and donald trump has said he won't
participate so we will see
but i understand your concern the last
thing we need is joe biden
getting the virus from donald trump
and then lastly from the subreddit user
flameboy
says unless i've missed something did
anyone else notice there's been no
videos released of bunker baby since he
got back to the white house it'll be
interesting to see how long it is until
we see
another one with all of his cronies
repeatedly saying
that everything is fine well we finally
got a video from trump from
from the white house and that's what i
will talk about next
but you can join the discussion on the
david pakman show subreddit at
davidpakman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t okay
let's get into it donald trump in a
continued effort to show us how great
he's doing how healthy he is
has put out another video in which he
calls catching
covid a blessing from god
but the real worthiness of the news
video is that
donald trump looks terrible he sounds
terrible he doesn't even seem to know
what day it is or how long he was in the
hospital so let's look at it
this is nearly a five minute video we're
not going to look at all of it but the
first thing you notice
as we just play some video without audio
for our audience
that's watching is that donald trump's
face
looks completely bruised and i think
that what they did is deliberately put
him under a tree
so that there's a shadow on his face
from the branches
but that's not all that's going on in
other words his right cheek seems
bruised his right eye is almost
completely swollen
shut for most of the video his lips seem
like the only thing on his face that
don't have makeup and they are
absolutely white as a ghost it's an
image of a man
not doing particularly well despite
claiming now for days
that trump has had no symptoms but when
you start
listening to what trump says you can't
help but notice that donald trump
is cottonmouthed short of breath and
slurring even more than as usual for him
let's look at the first clip hi perhaps
you recognize me it's your favorite
president
and i'm standing in front of the oval
office at the white house
which is always an exciting place to be
i got back
a day ago from walter reed medical
center i spent four days there
so it's already very strange because
trump says i got back a day ago well
when this was released
yesterday trump had already been back at
the white house for two days
now maybe the explanation is simple
maybe they filmed
it tuesday but published it wednesday
but then donald trump says he spent four
days at walter reed
he didn't trump spent about 54 hours at
walter reed
he didn't spend four days there he
didn't even spend parts of four days
there so
again it's raising questions of is trump
okay how connected to reality is donald
trump
this continues we'll skip ahead a little
bit and then you'll start to notice
donald trump sounding hoarse
and struggling to breathe again but i
spent four days there
and i went in i wasn't feeling so hot
and within a very short period of time
they gave me regeneron
it's called regeneron and other things
too but i think this was the key but
they gave me regeneron
and it was like unbelievable i felt
good immediately i felt as good three
days ago as i do now
so i just want to say we have regeneron
we have a very similar
drug from eli lilly and they're coming
out and we're trying to get them
on an emergency basis we've authorized
it i've authorized it
and if you're in the hospital and you're
feeling really bad
i think we're going to work it so that
you get them and you're going to get
them free
and especially if you're a senior we're
going to get you in there quick so this
is interesting because as of this
recording
somewhere between 10 and 25 people
total in the entire country had received
this
antibody cocktail from regeneron trump
says he's going to give it for free to
every senior in the hospital maybe to
everybody even
now maybe that's a nice idea remember
this is an
unapproved antibody cocktail as of yet
but how do you get something that's been
given to only
10 or 25 people total how do you get
that to every senior in the hospital
with coronavirus
for free in any case he says that
there's many doses coming online
it's an interesting idea but it doesn't
seem to connect with reality
we continue donald trump briefly says
vaccines are coming soon
i won't be playing that since it's the
same thing he's been saying on vaccines
for a while
but then he gets into this getting
covered
was a blessing from god stuff and that's
what i want for everybody i want
everybody
to be given the same treatment as your
president
because i feel great i feel like perfect
so i think this was the blessing from
god that i caught it
this was a blessing in disguise i caught
it
i heard about this drug i said let me
take it it was my suggestion i said let
me take it
and it was incredible the way it worked
incredible
so when trump says that he feels perfect
that's of course really tough to believe
when he's
slurring with cottonmouth looking
bruised with his right eye swollen shut
and struggling to breathe but this idea
that now that trump has gotten the virus
he's over
some hump and now he can really start
dealing with it
it is an insult to everyone who didn't
have the care that donald trump got in
his six-room suite at walter reed
it's an insult to everybody who died
merely because
i guess up until now trump didn't really
get it
uh and who had family members die and
the entire thing
and as always it's what's the phrase a
day late and a dollar short
uh this is more than that this is seven
months late
and 215 000 deaths too late
and we continue to be very skeptical
that donald trump is actually healthy
and to be very clear
the the speculation that donald trump is
not doing so well
it's not about making fun of people who
have coronavirus
it's not about anything other than they
lie about
everything and the hypocrisy of saying
hillary had parkinson's and biden has
dementia
while obviously lying about the health
of donald trump
the hypocrisy knows no bounds and we're
going to have more about this on the
david pakman show instagram page which i
hope you're following
at davidpakmanshow on instagram
and we'll just have to see what trump
looks like by tomorrow
again seemingly bailed out on the debate
because
he doesn't want to do it remote but
we'll talk about that a little bit later
in today's program
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top quality materials
and they just look great i went on their
site and picked out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 percent off everything in
their store
when you go to davidpakman.com vincero
i've put the link right underneath this
[Music]
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today corey doctorow who's the author of
two new books how to destroy
surveillance capitalism
also attack surface the third
installment
in the new york times best-selling
little brothers series
corey so great to have you on today it's
my pleasure thank you for having me on
so to start with we've talked about
surveillance capitalism on the program
before but as someone who's who's really
written a lot about this
how do you explain the concept to
someone who may not be familiar with it
well it should be noted that i i don't
agree with the
majority criticism of surveillance
capitalism yes i i think that um
the the majority criticism goes
basically google invented a mind control
rate to sell you a fidget spinner and
then robert mercer used it to make your
uncle racist
and and i think that you know this gives
google way too much credit it gives big
tech too much credit the the
history is littered with people who
claim that they could influence us with
technology
um and mostly what they do is influence
their potential customers like
advertisers to give them a lot of money
but then under
deliver i think there's every indication
that that's what google
and facebook and other ad tech companies
are doing which is not to say that they
aren't spying on us like crazy
they are and it's not to say that that's
not harmful it super is
and it's and it's not to say that they
don't distort our discourse they do but
they do so because they're monopolists
and monopolists get to subvert the
regulatory process so they can do
dangerous things like
over surveillance and over retention of
data and then you know if there's only
one place we go to ask questions
the answer that they give us matters a
lot to what we believe but
not because they have a mind control ray
just because they become a canonical
source
so for people who have read about
surveillance capitalism often uh it's
shashana zubaf's work that that
folks may be may be familiar with so
correct me if i'm wrong and i'm glad for
you to kind of go into this it seems as
though
maybe you you believe that shashana is
correctly
identifying some of the characteristics
but
the conclusions that she comes to are
not necessarily your conclusions
yeah so i think that zuboff really does
believe
that machine learning allows us allows
tech companies to manipulate
us to take away what she calls our right
to the future tense right the right to
to be able to decide for ourselves what
we'll do in the future and i think that
um
that's not true of machine learning but
it's totally true of monopoly
right if all of your friends are
corralled on facebook then
facebook can tell you with a high degree
of accuracy that you're going to have to
stay on facebook to talk to them
and uh you know a way to maybe visualize
the difference between our points of
view
is that she thinks that traditional pro
competition remedies like breaking the
companies up or opening them up to
interoperability or anything else that
we might do to
reduce their power will just produce
like
hundreds of pipsqueaks each of them with
their own mind control rate and we won't
even be able to keep track of them and
how they're using them
so imagine that there was a comet headed
towards earth and you had someone who
said no no
we can't try and break the comet up if
we do it'll turn into a million meteors
and they'll just smash every city on
earth
we have to we have to steer the comet
and that's what she thinks right she
thinks we need to
tame the companies by telling them what
they can and can't do putting them under
tighter control and so on
and i just don't think you can put them
under control for so long as they have
monopolies
because they have so much excess money
from being monopolists
and they're so concentrated that they
can agree on how to spend that money
that they can end up steering their own
course you know people look at that
picture of the tech leaders with donald
trump in 2016 at the top of trump tower
on that table meeting with them and they
go like
how can tim cook and all these other
self-described bastions of liberalism
meet with donald trump and that's a fair
question but a better one is
how is it that everyone who runs tech
fits around a single table
that that should be even more alarming
and so when you
talk about the how the the monopoly
aspect
is a big piece of why the status quo
is as it is let's talk through what it
would look like if that if that weren't
the case because i could imagine
that if instead of facebook google
amazon you know
pick pick the five and say instead
there's ten
in each instead of each of the five i
could imagine well
if everybody is more spread out rather
than on one platform
it's harder to be as accurately
predictive about how people are going to
be
behaving online because you've only got
a fraction of the data rather than a
huge portion of it at the same time
there's the money argument which is
if you have 50 players instead of five
no one of them is going to be so well
funded that maybe they can so so how how
much of it is
is the the financial piece how much of
it is the sort of network effect of
everybody being on on
a few platforms well let's talk about
network effects because um
historically network effects for tech
were not as durable
as they are in other areas like say
railroads right network effects and
railroads are super powerful because
once you've got the rails
everyone's got to use them and no one
wants to build a second set of rails
next to your rails
right but if you're say ibm and you have
this giant printer division called
lexmark
and you have the network effects of of
having this huge customer base
uh and you then decide to extract high
rents for
your toner right the carbon that you put
into them and use a security chip to
make sure no one puts their own carbon
in it carbon is obviously a very
abundant element we're struggling to
deal with an overabundance of carbon
not hard to get all the carbon you need
so along comes a little taiwanese
company called static controls and they
use the network effect like judo
because they say hey look ibm has
created this huge market of people who
bought subsidized printers
we can sell them cheap toner they clone
ibm's chip right they make an
interoperable chip
and now they own lexmark they bought
lexmark from ibm
or if you're apple and you're being out
competed by microsoft and the enterprise
because microsoft deliberately breaks
compatibility between microsoft office
for the mac and microsoft office for
windows
you can just say well to heck with
microsoft we're just going to reverse
engineer how microsoft office works and
release the iwork suite pages and
numbers and keynote
so that mac users can just interoperate
with windows users so
what i think is that when people have
problems
with the way that tech works uh and and
those problems can be the result of tech
trying to do something harmful to them
like manipulate them or can just be the
result of tech not considering their
uses right uh
you know the the technology that we've
all encountered that assumes that you've
always got a reliable internet
connection
has proved a lot less reliable than we
hoped it would now that we're all stuck
at home and
sharing our internet with all of our
neighbors all day long
you get to modify it or you get to find
someone to modify or someone identifies
you as a market and modifies that tech
so that it suits your needs and not the
needs of the shareholders of the people
who made it in the first place
and that in that world the equilibrium
we get is companies competing to see
how happy they can make you not
companies competing to see
how tightly they can control your
actions in the future so that you're
stuck with them
i i want to continue down this path but
one
sort of small tangential issue i'm
curious to get your thoughts about is
i was recently speaking to someone in
the tech space who said you know with a
lot of the you pick pick
some niche area where there's like one
one big player
um if you were to all of a sudden get 10
players in that same space
in all likelihood they'd all be using
amazon web services and so jeff bezos
basically could still flip one switch
and shut all 10 of them down
that that's a very practical concern but
it's a real one isn't it
it certainly is and that's why you know
traditional anti-monopoly remedies
um are include something called
structural separation which was in the
congressional report that was released
this week as well
and structural separation starts with
things like railroads being banned from
owning coal companies or freight
companies where they own
the people that they haul freight for or
they own
businesses that compete with the people
that they haul freight for
and you could imagine a structural
separation regime for amazon where they
say you can be a platform
or you can use the platform but you
can't compete with the users of the
platform if you own the platform
that's like the casino boss coming down
and gambling at the table opposite you
and the croupier knows that if if the
casino boss loses
that koopie loses their job too right we
want we want a level playing field there
um and i and i want to stress that
there's like a little nuance here
because
although i think the monopolies that
tech has created
are the same mediocre sociopathic
bullying tactics that
we saw with coal and that we saw with
electricity that we see today with like
beer
and with logistics and and so many other
industries that have become super
concentrated pro wrestling is down to
one league
right uh that there is one way in which
tech is very different and it is this
compatibility idea
that that making a pro wrestling league
that can interact with other pro
wrestling leagues seamlessly is hard
making a version of office for the mac
that can read and write
office for windows turned out to be
pretty straightforward
and the history of technology is filled
with these companies that had dominance
like
amazon and saw that dominance taken away
from them
because of inter-operators because of
competitive compatibility
making new things that plug into old
things even though the people who made
those old things
don't want you to and you're eating
their lunch by doing so
to pick one of the things you you
mentioned to dig into
a little deeper um our data the the data
about us about our activities
and big tech having that data using the
data
to market to us or through tracking
pixels
allowing third parties to target us in
in very specific ways
there's a panoply of ideas about
how and why this is bad can you focus in
on again
with your background in writing science
fiction as well and having no shortage
of connection to dystopian futures and
near futures and so on
what are the real concerns there about
big tech having our data which ones
maybe are overblown in your mind
so i i want to dig into this but it is
like a technical and complicated issue
so i'm just going to give you like a top
line here
yeah um when we release data or when we
uh uh harvest data and hold it and think
about the risk of it being released
non-consensually like it leaking or
being hacked from us or what have you
we try to anticipate the risks from that
data being released and when we give
data to companies we try to anticipate
those risks what could they do
with x and y and z x and y and z on
their own aren't a big deal so the nhs
and the uk where i used to live
did a controlled data release of
prescribing data longitudinal
prescribing data which is a super useful
thing to have so that you know they
they gave each patient a random
identifier and then they said which
doctor
prescribed which meds to that person on
what day which hospital
and we could see over through that
through that data set you could see you
know like is there a risk if they put if
your doctor puts you on statins
that you'll then have to go on tricyclic
antidepressants or something stuff like
that that is
hard to see in individual cases or in
studies but the data might reveal
so that felt like a safe bet you know if
you asked me to review that data release
i would have said i can't see any real
risk
in this release but then uh a
taxi company had a breach and that taxi
company was widely used by patients who
went to hospitals for prescriptions
and so now you can see the person who
went from david pakman's house
to this hospital to get these tricyclic
antidepressants
or hormones that are given to people who
are undergoing gender transition
or some other very sensitive prescribing
data that correlates exactly with david
going back and forth to the hospital
so in order to understand the risks of a
data harvesting
a data release or giving your data to
someone
you have to be able to anticipate all
the other data that might be collected
and released in the future
that's a very hard thing to be able to
understand
and so the the risk is effectively
infinite
right that it's it's it is a an
unquantifiable risk that happens when we
gather and create large data sets
and the lesson of history is that if you
collect data it will probably breach
and if you retain it long enough it will
absolutely breach
i mean the thing i always tell firms
when they ask me about this is
if the nsa couldn't stop snowden from
leaking
their documents right what makes you
think that you're going to be able to
stop someone from leaking your documents
we will pause our conversation there
with corey doctorow and go to a break on
the podcast radio
and television program my full
conversation with corey and
it is fascinating so far we'll be on our
youtube channel at youtube.com
slash the david pakman show the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at that's joinpacman.com p
a k m a n dot com if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so in the last 24 to 48 hours we were
told that despite
having coronavirus donald trump plans to
be at next week's debate with joe biden
which would be the second presidential
debate scheduled for thursday
donald trump however said this morning
that he's bailing out on the second
presidential
debate with joe biden and will not
participate
after the commission on presidential
debates decided that because of health
recommendations in light of donald trump
being a coronavirus super spreader those
are my words not the words of the
commission on presidential debates they
decided to move debate number two
to a remote debate rather than do it in
person
uh frank farenkopf who's the head of the
debate commission
told cnn they made this decision
themselves it wasn't a decision made
with the presidential candidates but
they made it based on recommendations
from the cleveland clinic which advises
the cpd
on health related issues in light of
coronavirus the statement put out by the
cpd
says that quote the second presidential
debate
will take the form of a town meeting in
which the candidates would participate
from separate remote locations well
donald trump
does not like it he was interviewed this
morning
by fox business host maria bartoromo
trump says he's feeling great and he
will not do a debate
via remote teleconference or video thank
you so much for being here
uh first question is how are you feeling
how is the first lady feeling this
morning
she's feeling good i'm feeling good
really good
i think perfect and uh we're ready to go
i'm ready to go accept the quarantine
situation that you have for a little
while after you
get tested or whatever the procedure is
but i'm ready to do i'm looking forward
to doing the rallies
i heard that the commission a little
while ago changed the debate style
and that's not acceptable to us uh i
beat him easily in the first debate
according to the polls that i've seen
but i beat him easily and
i felt i beat him easily i think he felt
it too he wouldn't answer any questions
and he had the uh
protection of chris wallace all night
long it was i thought i thought chris
wallace was a disaster
but i beat him in the first debate at
the second debate we have a never
trumper as a host but
that's okay because i beat him in the
second debate also
and uh but i'm not gonna do a virtual
debate
so you're not so mr president you're not
going to do it because the cpd
the commission on presidential debates
announcing this morning
that the second presidential debate will
be virtual you saying you're not going
to participate
no i'm not going to waste my time on a
virtual debate that's not what
debating's all about you sit behind a
computer and do a debate it's ridiculous
and then they cut you off whenever they
want trump seemingly at the end they're
admitting what this is really about
they can cut you off whenever they want
which donald trump doesn't want because
his strategy is to just keep talking
most importantly keep interrupting joe
biden speculatively the idea
is that trump believes maybe accurately
that constantly interrupting joe biden
will uh work will wreak havoc
with joe biden struggling with a stutter
his whole life
and that it is really you're not arguing
the issues when your idea is to just
keep interrupting the other the other
candidate
and now it starts to get wacky where
maria bartoromo
just can't control trump and we're going
to look at this in the next segment but
listen to this
uh i have a host who i always thought
was a nice guy but i see he's a never
trumper you know came out that he's a
never trumper
we do have some of them maria believe it
or not because they don't like to win
uh and uh but i'm not doing i'm not
doing reverse
they didn't even tell us about the
debate man when farrenkov was asked
about trump not participating
he said that it's totally trump's right
there there is no law
requiring a presidential candidate to
debate
uh frank farenkov said that in 1980
jimmy carter
refused to participate in the first
debate later participated in the second
debate
and the commission essentially saying
it's up to the candidate to decide do
they want to debate or do they not want
to debate so as of right now
and forgive me if this has changed it's
possible the commission will change
their plan
it's possible trump will change his mind
anything could happen but as of right
now
debate two scheduled to be remote and
donald trump
will not participate in that second
debate and it's
amazing how everything has come back you
know we talk about projection from the
from the trumpists
and how all of these things they accuse
others of are things they are doing
themselves
for months now trump has been saying
biden will bail
don jr others saying biden's going to
find a way out because biden just can't
do it
and it's actually donald trump who has
been the first to say
i'm not going to participate in a debate
i don't really know how much it will
hurt him
listen the other reality is the first
debate really hurt trump
trump's polling fell off a cliff
uh the day after the first debate we
started to see
a rapid ascent for joe biden and a rapid
decline for donald trump
so it almost might be better for trump
not to debate from the standpoint of
not doing even more damage by
participating it's certainly true
that not given the chance to interrupt
constantly which maybe trump wouldn't be
given if indeed the debate was done in a
remote format
it could be even worse for donald trump
so uh maybe he will end up participating
it's also conceivable that the cpd
will come to some agreement that there
was an idea thrown around
that they would move the debate outdoors
and have sort of a big covered area
where it's outdoors and socially
distanced with plexiglas
i still think it's conceivable that in
the next day or two
somebody proposes that and they say
given that we've been able to move the
debate outdoors and
account for this that and the other
thing that they'll do it in person again
it could happen
it might not there might be no second
debate i don't know how it's all going
to go does it turn into a joe biden town
hall
if donald trump simply doesn't
participate or do they cancel the event
altogether
i don't know but next i want to look at
some other clips from this interview
that trump did this morning
so let's now get into more of this
bizarre interview that donald trump did
with fox business host maria bartoromo
this morning
the big news from this interview was
that donald trump will not debate joe
biden next week as of right now
because the commission on presidential
debates decided it would be a virtual
debate
trump doesn't want it that was the sort
of big headline
but as this interview went on donald
trump was making less and less sense
shouting things out that had nothing to
do with what maria barto-roma was asking
about
and once again raising the question
about is trump
manic because of his use of
dexamethasone
is trump simply desperate because his
polling has imploded
does trump think yelling about hillary
on fox news will help his poll numbers
we don't know the answers to any of
these questions but i'm going to give
you a small
sampling of what went on here but what
is abundantly clear is this is not
a well person here donald trump claims
that he recovered from coronavirus so
quickly
because he's a perfect physical specimen
and then they just start talking over
each other
they being donald trump and the
interviewer maria bartoromo
tell me tell me how you felt what you
went through it's amazing to me that
you're back in such strong form right
now how did that happen you've been
talking about regeneron
eli lilly and regeneron want fda
approval for emergency use at this point
are they going to get it and they're
going to get it yeah they're going to
get it uh i
i'm back because i'm a perfect physical
specimen and i'm extremely young
and uh so i'm lucky in that way
uh and you know seriously
i don't have any i don't have heart
problems i don't have diabetes i don't
have any of the problems that you read
about
perhaps a couple of pounds we could lose
here and there but you know
there's a lot of people in that category
but no i'm in good health
and i'm uh you know like look what
happens
is if you're anywhere around this thing
you can catch it and
there's the big realization trump
finally
understands contagion isn't that amazing
if you're around it anywhere if it's
anywhere around you
you can catch it it's like seven or
eight months
since this started and trump finally
understands
if someone with the virus is anywhere
around you
you might catch the virus an incredible
learning experience for trump hasn't it
been
a trump on the joe biden town hall i
guess that joe biden did with lester
holt a few days ago
trump very angry about it but it's not
totally clear what he's talking about
here
nbc disaster where he went on the show
with lester holt it was like
it was meant for a child it wasn't meant
for a
grown person uh he gets up and he says
we're not fracking
we're not fracking he was fracking for
six months he was fracking he was
raising his
his very thin hand and he was fracking
and now all of a sudden he's not
fracking well tell the pennsylvania
people that you're going
it's ridiculous he said he's not
fracking
raising his very thin hand it's not even
possible to guess
what this man is talking about here
trump then accuses
china of putting a curse
on the united states take a listen to
this it wasn't
our workers fault it wasn't our
airline's fault that china
did this terrible thing to us that i
will not be forgetting about that
china did this this was all done by
china and we shouldn't be hurting our
workers because china put the curse on
because this was a
a horrible scourge a horrible horrible
thing that they did
so the virus went from a biological
agent
released by a chinese lab months ago
that was their idea months ago
now it's simply a curse so sort of going
from a conspiracy to the occult
trump then calls for barack obama and
joe biden
to be indicted for crimes which of
course he can never enumerate
unless bill barr indicts these people
for crimes
the greatest political crime in the
history of our country
then we're going to get little
satisfaction unless i win
and we'll just have to go because i
won't forget it
but these people should be indicted this
was the greatest political crime in the
history of our country
and that includes obama and it includes
biden
these are people that spied in my
campaign
and we have everything now they say they
have much more okay
and i say bill notice that donald trump
still
after all these months of saying biggest
political crime in history
we caught them we have all the evidence
obama and biden did it to me
donald trump still isn't able to tell us
exactly what laws were broken exactly
what crimes barack obama and joe biden
committed but when you talk about my
political enemies should be indicted
that's something we're used to hearing
from other countries
but but not so much from ours except
under donald trump then trump
bizarrely says he's killed terrorists
who are bigger names
than osama bin laden it's all what
celebrity fetishism with trump take a
listen to this
we have the greatest troops in the world
i wiped out 100 of the isis caliphate
i killed solomani i killed al-baghdadi
names at everybody bigger names than
osama bin laden
uh al-baghdadi founded isis everything
is hyperbole
everything is superlative with this guy
bigger names than osama bin laden
it's always been about can i do more can
i do it better can i do it bigger than
barack obama
and then it really got wacky trump
reacting to last night's vice
presidential debate between joe bi
between mike pence rather and kamala
harris and trump says of kamala
she is a communist and then with no
shred of sarcasm or joking at all
says that joe biden wouldn't make it two
months as president it seems like he's
talking health-wise
uh uh industry here what was your
reaction to the debate
what wasn't said that you would have
liked to come out and where do you think
the most striking moments were
i thought that wasn't even a contest
last night
she was terrible she was
i don't think you could get worse and
totally unlikable and she is
she's a communist she's left of bernie
she's rated left of bernie by everybody
she's a communist we're gonna have a
communist and she's gonna be
in my opinion within a month look i
stood next to joe and i looked at joe
joe's not lasting two months as
president okay that's my opinion
joe biden won't last two months says
donald trump
of course without any evidence and
remember trump is the one that's sick
right now
and that came up as well on the issue of
trump
having coronavirus trump says he hasn't
been tested for coronavirus recently
but that he is essentially very clean he
says
pulled out of uh the senate hearing that
he was supposed to do mr president i
know you have to go just to recap you're
not going to do
the next debate because it's virtual
you're feeling good
i know i want to make sure that the
audience understands you're feeling good
have you been tested recently can you
tell us anything else
i'll be tested but i'm i'm essentially
very clean
they say it's over a period of six seven
days and uh
i was uh i you know it's an amazing
thing happened to me i just
went in and i didn't feel good and
that's okay i expected at some point
because i'm out there i've got to be a
leader i can't you know winston
churchill didn't sit in his basement for
six months i got a lot of things doing
i'm essentially
very clean famous last words
from donald trump one really wild thing
as maria bartoromo tries to end the
interview
this is wild trump yells out of nowhere
why hasn't hillary clinton been indicted
he just yells it out of nowhere
i'd like to come back to the white house
soon to do another interview mr
president
i'd love to come back to the white house
that hillary clinton being indicted
for terminating 33 000 emails that she
got from congress congress made a
request to see him
everybody else i know gets indicted when
they don't give that they don't give she
she destroyed 33 000 emails forget about
the fact that they were classified
let's go maybe mike pompeo finally finds
him okay
the interview was over as far as maria
bartoromo was concerned donald trump
interrupts and yells out
why hasn't hillary clinton been indicted
yet it's sort of a fitting conclusion
to a completely absurd interview and we
are seeing
a desperate trump yes the steroids may
be affecting his behavior
yes he still doesn't sound good he
sounds hoarse struggling to breathe
but there is desperation here because
donald trump on
some level must realize uh half his
campaign team has coronavirus
he's down in the polls he blew it
in that first debate he may now not even
be participating in the second debate
he must feel like this is slipping
through his fingers like sand
and uh he's desperate and this is what
we see when donald trump gets desperate
let's go to your voicemails now we have
a voicemail number
that number is 219 to david p
here's a really funny voicemail about a
pen about a fly landing on mike pence's
head during the debate take a look
bro pence is such garbage a literal
fly just landed on this guy's head
he is such trash that literally flies
are landing on his head what's the
opposite of when bernie gets a bird to
land on is
on his little podium it's when a fly
lands on pence's trash ass head
goodbye pants bye bye
yeah a lot of people reacting to the fly
that that took hold of
mike pence's hair and seemed to get sort
of caught up in his hair gel
um i i read a lot of interesting things
about how i i'm as you know i'm not
religious and i don't know if this is
old testament or new testament stuff or
whatnot but
i guess a fly landing on your head is
considered to be a very ominous sign at
least in some biblical teaching
and a bunch of people wrote to me wrote
wrote to me about that
it doesn't resonate with me but with
pence being such a religious guy
it is pretty damn funny we've got a
great bonus show for you today we will
update
the uh biden harris student debt plan i
think this is important and i want to go
over it
we will also talk about 24
super habitable planets that have
conditions
that are better for human life than
earth
better and we will also talk about the
lgbt
takeover of the proud boys hashtag on
the internet
it is absolutely hilarious all of those
stories and more on the bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but
making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero
today's show also sponsored by blinkist
blinkist is the app that lets you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
davidpakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video